you know my generation of women which I
would classify maybe under 35 20 to 35
roughly you know ish
um we really
I would argue have very little guidance
you know I talk a lot about the the
generation of shitty wives which I
classify as like the 40ish to 60 year
old women these women often worked
instead of watching their kids they
didn't submit to their husbands I mean
there sure as hell better than my
generation of women but I mean they
raised us so I mean we got it from
somewhere right so now we have women
coming out
and talking about
basically not sleeping with their
husbands let's pull the clip a couple
months ago it dawned on me I'm a
grown-ass woman why don't I have my own
bedroom I shared a bedroom most of my
childhood and when I finally got my own
bedroom it felt like I had arrived to
grown-up land and then I got married and
then I was sharing not just a bedroom
but a bed one day I was helping my
nine-year-old decorate and organize her
own bedroom and realized wait a minute
why don't I have my own bedroom
couple of fun benefits I got my own
bedspread I picked out my own pillows I
get to put all the pictures on the wall
that I want look how gorgeous this one
is
I was a little worried about how our
kids would react to Mom getting her own
bedroom I didn't want them worrying
about us but a week ago I was talking to
my daughter about going on vacation and
getting a little Airbnb and how many
rooms would we need and she goes well
Mom you've got to make sure you have
your own room
a grown-ass woman get yourself your own
bedroom and teach your daughter that she
could have her own bedroom her whole
life okay I want to talk about why this
is sad because essentially
I mean we know that dead bad brooms is a
very big problem right we know there's
uh
endless supply of women that are not
sleeping with their husbands okay we we
know this
and now she she's she might not have
said it
but
are couples that have separate bedrooms
generally known for being that into each
other sleeping with each other and at
the end she said I'm going to teach my
daughter the same and I want you guys to
understand that I do have I actually do
have a level of sympathy you know as
much as I go in on on
modern chicks right or like my
generation of women it's because like
genuinely nobody tells us the truth
nobody the media lies to us
conservatives lie to us liberals lie to
us nobody
um
and we go through our whole lives
thinking stuff like this is okay
um and listen to how gleeful she got
when she was talking about herself me me
it's the me me generation I care about
what I want
um did she think about what her husband
wanted what her husband thought it's no
it's all about her
and you can hear the level of like spite
in her voice
and you can hear like the spite of oh no
my husband's like in my thing I mean she
didn't say it but you could you could
just hear it like that she resents her
husband for making her share a room
when in history a lot of us grew up like
imagine you know like 200 years ago they
shoved everyone into like one bedroom
log cabins
and you're whining about not getting
your own room and this is why I laugh
when when couples talk about divorcing
over chores or whatever it's like do you
realize the things people used to have
to go through
and you just see the level of crazy
that's raising the next generation of
women like this is what we have for
wives and mothers we have nobody to
learn from
so a lot of times people go into this
being nice right and I say this in the
comments they probably did it because of
snoring or something like that they
didn't weirdly think sharing a bedroom
with their spouse was inherently bad
and you know I I understand giving
people the benefit of the doubt I
understand there's exceptions guys but
you know there's something about working
through discomforts
you know we used to have things that
bothered us about our husbands bothered
us about our wives and we would figure
out Solutions you know and you you
wouldn't separate but we all know that
separating rooms is the first step to a
divorce I mean if you think that that's
a good way to live so be it but
I I really just think we have women that
are publicly bragging about not sleeping
with their husbands you know a lot of
times what I hear from
the tradcon community is just find a
good woman
and you know what guys I think it
actually is a fundamental
misunderstanding of women women's nature
women we our emotions change every day
and I'll tell you this I know
very successful women very logical women
do like doing what I do I know like the
most logical chicks but women are still
women
and you have to understand that women
are emotions are the first thing that
override everything even me when I get
really stressed out that that's the
first thing that overrides me
and
when they say find a good woman it they
fundamentally misunderstand female
nature because even a woman a good woman
can do a bad thing on her worst day and
women have a tendency to always be
trying to do better and get attention
from higher and higher value men not
every woman's going to act on this right
the same way guys have a tendency to
just want to sleep with everybody they
have this super high you know they just
they they find the new chicks hot they
want to sleep with all the chicks and
you know there's biological reasons for
this women had to extract resources from
the highest value man that they could
and men had to spread their seed there's
reasons why we feel the way we feel we
don't just undo biology because we're in
modern times I I don't say you should
act on it right but to act like it's
unheard of that even a good woman would
do the wrong thing on her worst day and
you have to you have to guys you have to
get into 2023. the entire media is
telling us to do the wrong thing a lot
of our friends will tell us to do the
wrong thing
um
we can build careers off of doing the
wrong thing divorce books
Tick Tock careers
um and we have it marketed that doing
the wrong thing is fun and amazing and
awesome so there's a guy named Tyrese
Gibson and he's recently going basically
to the cleaners in divorce and child
support and this is a guy he's handsome
he's good looking
um he's rich like what what more could a
woman want he seems to have character he
doesn't seem to be out there like that
he seems like a good guy
and you know he's pointing out that even
a good woman can do the wrong thing on
her worst day so he said Tyree said that
his ex-wife reassured him before
marriage that she didn't want his money
and signed a prenup but is now finding
ways to access his money so this was a
woman that was very simple who I met in
a 12 sundress and prided herself on
being simple and I don't care about
money Stars celebrities I don't need to
live and be around this is not I'm a
simple girl now you want twenty thousand
dollars a month for a one-year-old now
you've hired three law firms my
prenuptial agreement was so detailed and
so extensive
my lawyer whispered she had her own
lawyer to negotiate on her behalf my
lawyer Tanya Mitchell Graham said to me
I can't believe you got her to sign this
and I said well the reason I got her to
sign it is because she said to me
specifically
this ain't mine that's your publishing
those your car's your house and if we
ever separated because I didn't get in
this for any of that I will sign every
piece of paperwork that reflects that I
don't want none of that to then
want nothing more than the show with
negative that's all she wants
and women can switch up even even
seemingly good woman she signed the
prenup
she was in a 12 sundress and it's so
funny because they'll they'll still find
a way to blame the guy like this can't
happen to an average dude
prenups are not foolproof and the
problem is traditional men are punished
I we need to ban divorce we need to ban
alimony we need to ban child support
women should not be rewarded for making
the wrong decision no way no
um Levy television says nah bro she's
asking for 20K for what you put her
through
Jesus Christ what oh oh being a
housewife is so hard my husband was mean
to me sometime
and now you deserve 20K a month
do you guys live in absolute delusion
what the hell do you need 20 km you're
so funny I'm gonna tell you what's so
funny what's so funny
the richest people I know
don't live like that that are the most
wealthy they don't need 20K a month and
it's these stupid well you know what
honestly they have to be somewhat smart
to pull this off but like it's like
these idiotic women that ruin it for
women that actually want traditional
outcomes ladies let's let's talk to the
traditional women out there the women
that want to be married that want to be
wives that want to be mothers we need to
start shaming this
this this stuff is so dead I'm so tired
of seeing it I'm so tired and I'm so
tired of women defending this
where'd you married her she had your
baby and now you want her to go through
struggle everybody freaking struggles
then work it out stay with the guy
or go get remarried or go get a job like
the rest of the world these entitled ass
women think that they deserve the world
because they gave birth
dogs give birth every animal gives birth
you are not that special just because
you gave birth to somebody G Alice from
Wonderland what a joke he's a rich man
and his child deserves to live the same
way then give him custody let him have
the kid that's my answer to it if you
can't afford the kid then give it to the
dad and the thing is do you think a baby
knows the difference a children know the
difference between being rich and being
poor
uh all they want is their parents the
best thing you could do and it's so
funny because these women will cry about
how the kids need money but you know
what they need a freaking dad that's the
most important thing that's what a kid
that's what the kids want they want to
see their father and now you have kids
being graced by daycare workers being
raised by nannies being raised by
grandmothers and lazy mothers who don't
want to do their job which is what
they're supposed to be a wife
this crying on the internet hoping
for people to agree with him is so low
from my understanding she only asked for
the same amount that he pays his other
kid 10K that person got away with
robbery so therefore I should Rob too
and you know what's funny men are
actually pretty good people they're
pretty generous most women honestly if
they're Pleasant
to their baby father if they're actually
a nice good person they'll freely give
you money that's the funny thing that's
the funny thing about this whole thing
if you have to take your guy to the
cleaners what does that say about you
because you know I actually you know and
I've spoken with guys that have gone
through a divorce but the woman was
actually a good person through it all
I I actually know women that gave up
custody
because they wanted what was best for
their children
and it was extremely hard for them it
was so hard
but they knew that was what was best for
the kid but the problem is these chicks
only care about themselves and they get
spiteful and jealous and they just want
more and more and more and they are
never happy and I'm tired of this I'm
tired of women defending this I'm tired
of men pandering To Us by saying we
deserve this and we deserve the world
because we gave birth I'm tired
so you know guys if you if you think if
you're tired of this too let's take
away women's right to vote get yourself
a t-shirt today uh from the audacity
Network dot store we actually have them
in person everybody here's got a shirt
now so like the video on your way out
um guys get to 2 000 likes that's the
most important metric that YouTube uses
to push out these streams so hit that
like button subscribe to the channel
I'll talk to you next time